on this episode of cloud ai adventures
i've invited megan rizdahl to join me on
the show
together we'll cook up our own data
science project on
kaggle how are you doing today megan i'm
doing great thanks so much for having me
on your show
awesome and before we get going i wanted
to let you
have a chance to talk a little bit about
what you do at kaggle and your role
sure so i'm the product lead for
datasets at kaggle
and what that means is that i work with
our engineers our designers as well as
our community to build tools
that help data scientists find share and
analyze data
and today what we want is for kaggle to
be the best place for our 1.7 million
data scientists
to share and collaborate on data science
projects awesome and so
today we'll be working together to use
the freshest ingredients
data and prepare them using different
tools and
work together to come up with our
delicious outcome
this public data set and notebook that
we can share with the world
that has a cool analysis to go with it
yeah that's exactly right
and i'm excited today because we're
going to really make this a
collaborative project
um so that's how we're going to get
things done is together teamwork
teamwork all right let's go so megan on
a previous episode of ai adventures
i had a video that showed how to get
started with kaggle kernels and it was
pretty
rudimentary in terms of just get started
go
it's awesome it's a free resource but
since then there's been a couple new
features released
that really enhance the functionality of
kaggle
both kernels and data sets to be used as
a great
tool for individuals and teams yeah
that's exactly right um so today kaggle
is
a really great place for people who use
r and python to work with data
that are looking really to build data
science portfolios do data analysis work
or even share research it takes a lot of
tools to do data science
and kaggle really acts as this one-stop
shop
that provides all these tools that makes
this possible from working with data
privately
to sharing it with the world and that
really you know it's it's really
fantastic
let's explore a little bit more about
the fact that kaggle datasets and
kernels
can support this kind of collaborative
model this private mode if you will
so you know some of recent features are
ability to publish and work with uh
private
data sets um and kernels um
you know and speaking of kernels this is
basically like a laptop in the cloud
it's more powerful powerful than the
laptop that i'm working with here today
um you've got 16 gigs of ram four cpus
six hours of compute and one of the
really exciting things is that
it is all in a docker container that has
all of these packages
that data scientists love pre-installed
so you've got this environment this
one-click environment
and then finally we're starting to add
on more customization so
if there's any packages missing i can
install those
or even do things like add a gpu yeah
very nice we've picked out a particular
data set today
to to play with around kind of data from
the city of
los angeles if i understand it correctly
yeah that's right
so a lot of governments and
organizations from
you know around the world in the united
states are
making open data available as part of
their open data initiatives to make
their work more transparent
so i'm from los angeles i live in los
angeles
and i was kind of interested in taking a
look at some of the open data that the
city of los angeles makes available
um so i was poking around on their open
data portal and
uh this one caught my eye because i'm a
little bit of a foodie it's a little
interesting but um uh it's actually an
environmental health code violations uh
from
restaurants and markets in los angeles
okay
all right let's get into it yeah yeah
yeah so what i've done is i downloaded
the data set um so it's on my local
machine right now
great um and what we're gonna do is um
upload it to kaggle this is gonna be the
foundation of our project
awesome and one of the things that
a lot of times you know i hear about is
you know some people are concerned
around
distributed computing and massive data
sets and you just mentioned
you downloaded this data set to your
local machine and
some folks say you know oh i need lots
of compute and resources
you know is kaggle going to be powerful
enough to
support my use case and one i guess
you know looking at cargo and just the
vibrant community you mentioned it was
at 1.7 million
yep that's where we're at today that's
amazing it clearly shows that
there are so many use cases beyond the
massive massive data sets
out there there's the the situations
where you can get away with just one
kind of powerful machine that can take
you
quite far yep that's right yeah and we
people are uploading
uh thousands of data sets per month yeah
wow yeah
all right so let's go over to your
laptop and see
how we go about doing that how do we
make a new data set on kaggle sure
um so we're going to start from the data
sets page
on kaggle's website um so this is what
it looks like and basically this is
where you have access to all of the data
sets that have been
publicly published on kaggle and we're
going to add our own today
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
click new data set
and then from here it's just a matter of
dragging and dropping the files that
i've chosen
to upload and these are inspections
of restaurants and markets in los
angeles and then violations
and then we're going to add a little bit
of metadata to get the data set started
okay so i'm just going to grab
all the information i need here okay so
we're going to keep it private because
um like we talked about we we want to
sort of um
prepare the data set so that it's um
well documented and then we're also
gonna play around with the data a little
bit
um and create some kernels before we
share it publicly yeah awesome
and that's definitely something that
folks uh i think don't get talked
doesn't get
talked about as much is documentation
for data sets yep that's
documentation from code is very well
understood and people you know hammer
that home but
documentation about data sets is kind of
a new concept right yeah it's really
about
making data accessible it's not just
making uh you know the data files itself
machine readable
so having well-formatted csvs
but also helping anybody who's
interested in working with this data
really understand it
so i'm going to go ahead and just click
on create data set fantastic
all right and your private data set was
successfully created
yay cool um so now the
the private data set was uploaded and
like it tells us here
now we can do anything from uh starting
to analyze the data set already
um to adding collaborators and we're
going to do both of those things
fantastic
so we'll click confirm and it's going to
take us to our data set
looking good yeah um like a real thing
yeah that's right so what we want to do
when people create a private data set is
make it easy for them to then make that
data set public eventually
and share it with the community so we
provide this quality checklist
that helps people basically document
their data set
and help them be successful when they
share it
so we're just going to quickly go
through this quality checklist
so the first is providing a description
and this is just a markdown file so i
have it saved here
great yeah i mean that's really nice
that you there's like this
um some guidance on what sorts of things
to add in to make a data set
nice yep yeah that's great for a good
experience yeah so i think that
things like understanding the context of
the data and why it's interesting and
why you're sharing it
is important as well as providing more
details about
the contents of the data set so that's
what we've done here
and then also you know inspiration uh
so some questions that you can use the
data to answer right
yeah yeah i've seen that in some of the
other you know data sets out there
now i know kind of why
there's some guidance there that's right
yeah yeah so then the next thing
um on this page is we're going to add
just a couple of tags and this helps
make the data set more discoverable once
we're ready to share it publicly
right so we'll do public health and food
and drink
okay seems reasonable um
so then we're going to add a subtitle
and a banner
image and this is just to sort of add
that final coat of paint to
make it look good and again help people
understand what the data set is about
yeah a little a little flare yeah that's
right
okay um so we'll save that
and we want them to replace this image
yep so this is what people will see
in the dataset listing um and
you know you're not supposed to judge a
data set by its cover but
you know if it has a flashy image that
can only help
yes i always pick data sets i have an
image of a sliced onion over ones that
don't
that's right uh looks delicious
um and then finally the most important
part is i'm going to add you as my
collaborator on this data set
so now i get to see it yep okay
so eventually there you are and
i will grant you edit access well thank
you
megan rizdel invited you to edit the
data set
great and so i can click view on kaggle
yep and
let's see what that looks like awesome
so this looks
basically the same as it looks on your
side yeah that's right
cool so we have uploaded our data we've
documented it and i've shared it with
you
one of the things that we like to
encourage people to do is to also
document their co their data sets
through code
so what i mean by that is publishing a
kernel on a data set is one way to
demonstrate to users and other people
in the community what they can do with
your data so
we might want to show somebody in a
kernel how they can read in the data
some of the things that we can visualize
using the data questions that can be
answered using it
yeah i mean when i see data sets
on kaggle these days they all have these
like exploration notebooks with
fancy visualizations and it's really
nice yeah
yeah exactly and when you start working
with a with a new data set
usually when you're working locally
you're starting from a blinking cursor
you don't have any code that shows you
how to read in the data and how to work
with it so that's what we're going to do
is we're going to additionally document
our data set by publishing a kernel on
it so fantastic
let's get started i'm just going to
click on this this big blue button as we
call it
new kernel yes so here we have a choice
between a script and a notebook
i'm going to go with notebooks because i
like interleaving markdown and code
and then while this starts up i can see
that i have the data
accessible right here at my fingertips
in my environment
great and i'm going to change the
language to r
i am an r stats person that's right all
right
cool uh so what i've done is i've
actually already i cheated and i already
prepared
the code that i'm going to use so i'm
just going to quickly upload it here
and then i'm going to walk you through
what i've done to analyze the data set
great um so in the first cell we have
the
inspections csv file and the violation
csv file so i'm going to go ahead
and read those in join them together by
serial number
and then take a glimpse at uh the
resulting data frame
okay so once that's done you can see
that we have almost 900 000 records that
we're looking at so these are
all health code violations for about two
years of data
okay it's a lot for two years yeah it's
yeah it seems like it so we're going to
dig into into what that looks like
so what i want to do now that i've got
the the data set kind of prepared and
the shape i want it is look at the
number of violations reported over time
by month
right this is the the big one yep
exactly
all right all right so you can see how
quick and snappy that is and we've got
this visualization that's cool right in
front of us
um so that's a lot of health code
violations yeah it's all over the place
what is that
like what's that bar 30 000 yeah that's
right
in a month yes yep that's a doozy
yep um so let's take a look and see if
there's any kind of like
seasonal trends um we also have
information about
uh what the violations were um for each
serial serial number okay so we'll take
a look at that
um and we're gonna look at just the top
10 violations so that's what this
code is going to be doing here
so we run that and now we're going to
get wow
very nice color coding here yeah is that
the darker one is more or the lighter
ones are more the lighter ones are more
okay yep um yep so you can see
this one here is a violation of the code
for floors walls and ceilings are
properly built maintained and good
repair and clean
okay yeah it's always comforting to know
that your establishment is in good
repair
yep that's right um
yep and then finally um i'm gonna just
save another project for later that i
have in mind is i want to look at the
violations
by zip code so we've also got
information for each right
of the facilities what their address is
so we can look at
you know whether or not there's more
violations by zip code and kind of look
at you know a geospatial
analysis but i want to do that a little
bit later so
i'm just going to write out that csv to
a file and i'll be able to use that
um in another kernel right and you can
imagine
kind of i'm just trying to think about
like this new output that you've created
you could make
some kind of mapping with it you could
do the one of those fancy uh
color coded heat maps right yeah we have
this sort of heat maps which
shows the violations by type but you
could also show
yeah like a chloroplast math and a map
geostatistic
yeah chlorapleth um
yeah exactly and you can see now how
taking just a peek at this data set has
already inspired new questions and
that's what exactly
what we want to do for our users so
i'm going to go ahead and give my
notebook a title
yes always good to have a title yep and
then i'm going to hit
commit and run okay so let's hit that
and
while that's running a question for you
does
the notebook not save if you haven't
clicked commit and run
like if you were to close that tab
before you click that what would happen
to all that code all that work
uh so it's saving a draft but if you
want to save your code and come back to
it later and share it with other people
you want to hit commit and run
and what that does is it executes the
code
from top to bottom right perfect
and so once that's done
i guess what is our next step what's our
plan here with
because right now we have a data set
that's private but shared between us
and we have this kernel which i think is
still just private to you right
yep yeah so once this is finished
i'm going to go ahead and click view
snapshot and this is going to
take us to the notebook viewer and from
here this is what i'll be sharing
uh with the world and this is what
somebody looking at the data set can
come and
come and find so i'm going to go ahead
and
again share this with you just to make
sure that
you think that all of our work is ready
to be made public right yeah so in a
team environment you could do this to
essentially do some sort of code review
scenario yeah exactly okay so once
you've done that
i can go over here on my laptop and
in the data set click kernels and go to
your work which i guess in this case is
your work
right and we'll open up your notebook
here
and you can see that it loads nicely and
i have the option to either edit
or to fork yeah notebook yeah so why
don't you go ahead and fork it and just
make sure that
you know everything runs as as expected
you can get everything to compile
cool so when i fork it is that
then similar to when you fork a repo on
github
right where you make your own copy now
this is like really mine yep this is
your copy of not just the code but also
the data that i used and the environment
that i used
okay gotcha and so anything you now make
changes to
on your side won't affect my copy
correct
okay so now i'm running it and this will
generate a different
kernel um do i need to change the name
will there be kind of a name collision
there if i leave it the same
uh you you don't need to change it um so
uh the slug that gets used is your
username and then the
the slug of the the notebook title
gotcha okay
so i could change it but i don't have to
right so now if i
go back to oh we can watch it do its
thing
um and i could share my fork with other
folks
yep that's right okay and we can see our
data
and if i click back now i guess this is
it should be once it finishes it'll just
show up
there there it is and there it is all
right awesome so what do you think
it's pretty good pretty good i guess
it's it's time to um
make this thing public for real yeah
let's go public all right
cool so i'm gonna go back to the data
set
and then i go to settings sharing
and if we think we're ready we can click
make public
all right let's do it so this is a
make public permanently that's right
great so it's always
good to know what you're getting into
here
nice and there we go and then the next
step is of course we want to make the
kernel public
oh right because the kernel itself is
separate from the data set so those
two concepts are distinct that's right
and so in this situation it could be one
where you wrote some stuff
and then you make yours public but then
i
fork it and it's private and i can
extend it privately
with you or with other folks and then
release
another version perhaps with some
different yeah exactly
so that flexibility is up to you awesome
yep uh so now our data set is public and
anybody from
our community of data scientists can go
ahead and explore more about uh
restaurant inspections and violations in
los angeles county that's right
that's right and zooming out and looking
at
what we've covered today it's quite
quite a bit and
the tools are all kind of in this
package in this really nice seamless
platform i have really enjoyed kind of
going through and you know we
made a notebook and data set on your
side we were able to share it across
privately and then publicly and you know
we didn't even get into things like
commenting system and the discussion
forums and there's so much more to
kaggle
but even this environment of
collaboration and sharing is so rich
yeah so we really did create a project
from start to finish
we got data files off of my local
machine
and into this reproducible documented
data set that's now publicly shared with
the world yeah and you can kind of see
how
somebody could do this for a school
project
or as a way to share research absolutely
yeah so this notebook is really public
so
if you're watching this video you can go
on kaggle right now
and access this data set we'll include
links to the notebooks
in the description below the video and
share and then you'll be able to see the
notebook the data set and
post comments fork your own notebook
make edits
thanks so much for joining me today
megan on the show it's been really fun
putting together this tiago kernel we're
making this data set and making it
public to the world
if you've liked this video be sure to
hit the like button
down below and click subscribe to get
all the episodes of cloud ai adventures
right when they come out
for now me and megan we're going to go
back to working on this kernel
but this time maybe i can convince her
to do it in python
we'll see about that